hello everyone alana here just wanted to
um apologize before you listen to this
episode for the terrible audio uh to
begin with
troy it'll be obvious to anyone who's
watching the video but especially for
our audio listeners um joined from an
airport and i guess his connection
wasn't great but i found the
conversation so interesting that i felt
like it should be included regardless it
just means the audio is pretty atrocious
um sorry about that but as soon as he
jumps off the call it clears up so if it
drives you two nuts you can just skip
ahead a bit if you like enjoy the show
i can't ask the host to give me
permission to record
you are those
no no host exists it's very strange
we are hostless
is it not automatically going to record
the audio anyway once you check that box
i think it stays checked oh maybe it
will
if so please delete everything we had a
conversation about up to this point
it's like
three of us have all
destroyed our careers in the first five
minutes of that recording so please
we all suffer oh hey troy hello there
what an entrance looked like you were
wearing a tie and then i got rid of
those real booksers those are fake books
i've always known troy was a fake yeah
yeah
if you're jealous of my bookshelf just
admit to it you do not have to descend
into printing make some books you know
what's sad is that it's literally the
champagne
that is prosecco you live in a different
world to the rest of us he does he is
through your hair
in different circles he's under control
yeah it is why we all being so cruel
that was a compliment that what are you
talking about it's cruel
so i just just i have no idea what i'm
interrupting
um i'm i'm going to barrel through
philosophical conversation of course oh
it's my favorite you're talking about
actors
man i i kind of want to get into there's
there's so much stuff we get into as
well like the starfire
whole situation um there was ign just
just tweeted out something
that i that i i
normally don't take offense to
much but that this one really got me
iggy and tweeted
you here is the other three of us
searching for ign it was yeah it was
literally ign tweeted i hate troy baker
troy
that one i
oh my god
this was actually instagram and they
said that uh
fans answer why they're not buying
vanguard
and
it's just a super like it's like a daily
mail
grabby headline
look at us it's like we interviewed like
500 people and 59 of them said that they
weren't buying it because
they had other games to play but i was
like you know that's damaging
and and already also what's wrong with
that what's wrong with that
justification
that's solid yeah also is it not selling
like
it's a false premise yeah but what
they're doing is they're going
they're there
it seems to me it seems to me like what
they were doing was
hey let's stir the pot on activision
blizzard and let's say how that is
affecting the sales of
you know
vanguard was just launched amidst this
conspiracy or not conspiracy but the
controversy not conspiracy
um and i just think accusations there
was a conspiracy yes
it is it is
to me this is this is why i just i i i
hate to use the the meme phrase of shake
my head at games quote quote games
journalism but it's like just if there's
nothing new to talk about there's a
breadth of stuff that you can talk about
before it's like hey i did this art i
just replayed x game or i just went back
and watched this one movie if you don't
want to stay within the games of space
go hey yeah right write articles about
the top 10 gaming podcasts that's a
farce what is up with that i had no idea
people were listening to this [ __ ]
i'm genuinely like surprised not to not
to derail troy's point i probably i
looked it up because someone tweeted yes
didn't they it's true yeah well that
person was alana
it was tweeted at me before that
that's definitely how i thought i was
like hey so troy i'm reading this and
genuinely this is genuine to me
mike bithell the reader this is
genuinely really interesting and useful
not a scientist
not a scientist the vanguard stuff is
genuinely
that's genuinely interesting to me
because i obviously sell video games so
it's interesting to see a breakdown of
why people what how people would respond
to the questions
they've played too much call of duty
lately 14 said they were already happy
with warzone another 11 they said they
were specifically waiting for another
game to play some offering battlefield
and halo as examples
um i genuinely find that data
interesting not doubting the body of the
article the body of the article and a
lot of you pointed out this as well
you as the writer correct me if i'm
wrong um
we could go to the tape too if we wanted
to but
you as the writer do not choose your
headline that is that is an editorial
thing that is someone that editor comes
in and chooses that headline no i said
the author
i i always chose my headlines but it is
it is pretty frequently like for the
daily fix there's a group of people um
you can often like have a bunch of
people bouncing back it it depends
there's no it's not always the same okay
yeah are you seeing the same headline as
metroid call of duty fans reveal why
they aren't buying vanguard do you think
that's like an inflammatory
i feel it's inflammatory i feel like i
feel it's going because automatically
what it says is that vanguard isn't
selling that it
passively makes that indictment
it could say
vanguard sales um have decreased over
previous
titles
fans answer why but to me it goes this
is the reason why it's not selling it's
like that's that's a false accusation
it's not selling it is so i will say
it's like selling less
that's in it
that okay so the data is actually from
games industry.biz so what ign did here
is just pull something from games
industry which is like okay it is kind
of bad journalism i think what gi did is
good journalism they actually got
statistics to something but i will say
this yeah
yeah out of this article says
this year's regularly scheduled call of
duty entry call of duty vanguard doesn't
appear to be doing as hard as previous
call of duty games in terms of sales is
one of the worst leading sentences what
does that mean is it selling by what
comparison also didn't during the cold
war didn't the cold war one like
like
it didn't that wasn't that one of the
best selling ones of of of of recent
years like so
once black ops yeah the cold war black
like my understanding was that that one
did gangbusters which would mean if it
did poorly relative to that it could
still be selling massive amounts of
units okay hang on modern warfare
but like right right now i'm looking i'm
in this airport lounge i'm on my way for
for another flight and i could walk
around to the the 20 people that i could
see and go excuse me are you buying call
of duty vanguard and i can get a data
set from these people
that and i could say no of all the 100
of the people interviewed said they
didn't have no interest in buying call
of duty vanguard it's true the sample
with that headline the survey says 671
that's not where they're deriving their
headlines from
they're not deriving their headline from
the answers to the question
they're driving their headlines from the
fact that they're not selling so i feel
like
they they are deriving it seems to me
that they're driving their headline off
of how can we frame this article
to to be a little provocative
provocative i thought i think i see what
you're saying it's really interesting i
also find it interesting and i don't
take offense to this i see what you're
saying is that the article you feel the
headline is written with the intent of
of throwing negativity at call of duty
from the jump
right it's like it's not selling here's
why i understand i understand what
you're saying
um well it looks like call of duty this
is only for the uk that
said because troy baker's not in it
and it was us we were the three who made
i'm a little i'm a little personally
biased because
my dear friend someone who is like a
sister to me is is in the game and i
have watched her systematically be in
incredible games
that because of the completely
irrelevant surrounding controversy
she has been properly able to celebrate
the fact that she is the lead in
something right we got uncharted four
last of us two and now vanguard and she
was just like
man you know she's so proud of her work
she's proud of the game she's proud to
be a part of the distinct
enterprise and franchise it's just like
and what i hate is that a lot of that
comes not from
real hard data going hey listen
and to me it pulls focus from what the
real with the conversation should be
which is active mission blizzard and the
the the 100
shift in management that needs to happen
there and the fact that you have ceos
that won't step down the fact that you
need system-wide or
industry-wide change that's the real
conversation
talking about how and again i fully own
that this is my perspective on this but
talking about how
that is affecting vanguard sales
base on max that's actually interesting
sorry about it yeah i just wanted to
give the data but um it uh just for
context that vanguard's launch in the uk
are down 40 over last year's game
however
it's still the second biggest game of
the year sure
that's what i mean like didn't i
wasn't curious
the reason for that is is a british
based
which by the way if anyone wants to read
good good really interesting stuff about
the games industry it's a fantastic
source
some really good wrestling i just don't
want to bloss past choice point about
interviewing the people in the lounge
though and then going zero percent
because they do you you're out on the
street right now troy can you please
just go ask somebody for the first time
troy before you do can i ask you can i
ask you a question troy before that
because you you triggered something
interesting to me there do you listen
i'm going to spin off at that time
because i have a question as far as the
data for that that specific browser tabs
are
open so as an actor
do you feel
personally kind of slighted or
frustrated when the press
talks negatively about the game you're
in obviously you care about the work
you've done but it seems i'm i guess i'm
surprised by sales i guess in particular
being like a thing that would frustrate
someone who you know by definition isn't
directly kind of harmed by that is it
just about raining on the parade or or
is it kind of more than that
when i was growing up
my i have an older sister she's two and
a half years older than me and she was a
loving sister we have a great to this
day we have a great relationship but she
was also still my big sister and she
would pick on me whenever she wanted to
right of course but i will never forget
one time bill horton was a guy that was
in my grade and he decided that was the
day
that he was going to beat me up after
school
and he did it in the soccer fields that
separated my elementary school from my
sister's middle school
and my sister i had not met her when i
normally was she was walking over to see
me and she saw billboard giving me a
woman
and my sister tore ass across that
soccer field and threw that child off of
me and she literally screamed get off my
brother
the point is is that she could do
whatever she wanted to with me
but haven't helped anyone
if they [ __ ] with me
and i feel the same way about the
studios that i work with you can say
whatever it's very it feels personal
feels personal totally fine
yeah but if you it to me it is picking
on people who i have a voice i can go on
a podcast i can go on uh
apparently people listen to whatever i
do
apparently people listen to this and i
buy and listen for tort or i don't
use my platform i can get on twitter or
whatever me too i i can i can somehow
respond to to what's being thrown at me
but the animator
or or someone who works at the studio
who doesn't have that bullhorn
to to
that there was a game that i was working
on today i can't get into
but i have
i i can say this there's four sessions
that i have to do that are devoted to
simply breathing
and it is wow
that the and we're talking it was and i
was like i watched like guys i can get
this done no time they're like actually
this is gonna be really hard
and there's just such attention to
detail that and they're they're put into
the games that nobody would think about
and that's the point they're supposed to
lay down and they're supposed to be no
wrinkle and smooth
and but there's people that work super
hard on just that one small thing
and so when someone goes what because i
want to have a headline that day
and it it
it affects that person that does that
job you're damn right i get i take that
personally and i do jump up and go right
first of all you don't know what that
person is different from that job so you
can say whatever you watch throughout my
performance but when you actually pick
on somebody else that's that's where
you'll you'll see me wrestle up and
you'll see me pick up my big sister
i understand
you are being
about being a big brother to laura is
what is what's happening
um there's definitely that because she's
she's an angel quite possibly the finest
that we have working in this industry
right now i have a question for you
alone yes so when it says that sales are
down 40
i don't know vanguard is
how many platforms is that also latched
in as well
um
because if you have fewer
people that have xboxes or playstations
your sales are going to be down
it says 40 over last year's game which
just means that no matter what across
the board every platform it is down um
forty percent um but let's see what
platforms it's available on
i just feel like there's it's not
everything goes into interpreting that
data you know
it's it well it's interesting though
because if that were the case you'd
expect that to be a response right
that's what's interesting about the
survey not putting aside the article
itself you would it would be really
interesting data for example if one of
the answers was i haven't got the new
console yet then that would be a really
interesting data point that doesn't
surface in the answers though which
implies that's not a reason people would
self-describe as not buying this game
although again the article is
interestingly 14 percent of players say
they're just still busy playing the last
call called you know very hard i
actually think warzone is probably a big
contributing factor to that statistic is
that they made their life
called
yeah yeah
that's why it's interesting that's why
the data is interesting it's less than
700 people out of packs
i know it means nothing it means
absolutely not it but the sales do the
the 40 down is interesting um and it i
would also i'd say a sample size of a
sample cyber size of 500 is still
a very interesting piece of feedback for
a game developer so i would say that's
less people there's more people in a
play tested every game i've ever made
i feel like if it's under a thousand i
would throw the data out the window
however it is a hardcore audience
because they did find them at a gaming
convention that's true but also pax has
a specific kind of flavor to it that's
true but to me it's also very different
the average pax crowd to me is different
than the average they're not your call
of duty gamers that is true
like again that framing is interesting
but it
feels coming in
the topic
it's like if you ask people you know
their favorite
taylor swift song at one of my concerts
you like
there's gonna only be there's probably
gonna be some over let's face it it's a
one-to-one overlap oh but that doesn't
mean you dismiss the data it's an
interesting framing that is really
useful but it doesn't mean the data is
not interesting or not useful that still
tells me it's really interesting but
it's questionable i actually think that
this data is not that useful
because
of
actually what austin said which is the
audience of a pax um is not necessarily
the audience who would play call of duty
anyway how do you verify that those
people are playing it but regardless the
40 statistic the 40 down and sales
statistic does make me go why so i do
want to know why i do want to ask people
why i do want to find out how that has
happened and i'm sure there's a bunch of
people being paid a lot of money at
activision to figure that out um
maybe they should you know be spending
more time firing bobby cote but anyway
uh you know everything that only takes
five to ten people though that's that's
like that's like that's remember
mike something you said i've taken
where it's every feedback is usable and
i've
and it's really stuck with me i i feel
like even if it was your game sucks like
okay that's there no i
if i'm possible like this to me is a
transcended trip yeah it has value the
the
the switch the difference to me is what
do i do with that data do i completely
course correct do i go oh one person
said this sucks but the data is still
usable and i think that is transcend
across everything whether you're making
games or anything
how much value
does the external have to you and what
do you do with that that's the real
truth so to use austin's example if
someone you interviewed randomly what's
your favorite taylor swift song they go
i kind of guess i haven't listened to
this new record no one's listening to
their taylor swift record is the same
thing that i feel like iga is doing with
this how those people interviewed that
is a true statement and technically you
are right so again technically you
should be blaming games industry um they
are the original source ign just
re-reported it it was gi that that is
the source for this and their survey
yeah why didn't people visible
that is to my point ign has the volition
and they have the ability to go whether
or not we're going to run with this i
don't blame the data i don't blame the
article that's written what i do
kind of whack my finger at a little bit
is going i'm going to create a headline
and put it on social media because we're
not scrolling we're not in people's
timelines enough and that's what i feel
i could be wrong about now i really
genuinely wish that we had a
conversation with the person that was
responsible for that single post because
that would that to me would be useful
data
but i i just feel like this that speaks
specifically to my point of of what mike
says as far as every feedback is useful
but what you do with it you i still have
the opportunity to choose how i want to
respond i literally sat there whether or
not i was going to write a comment and i
i wrote do better and i was like it
doesn't sound like you you don't do that
and then i was like okay i need to be
more exhausted and then i went i don't
have to comment on this at all i have
the ability to just keep scrolling not
comment at all or even better put my
phone down
so that i guess that's my
point if there's a moral
oral percentage of tweets that should
undergo that evolutionary process where
you write it and then you don't hit send
and then you delete it that's about 85
percent of all tweets i mean i would
have no contents if i if i applied that
rigorously
more than anybody else i follow you'll
tweet something and then i'll see your
reply or somebody else and the tweet's
deleted and i'm like what did he say why
is he keep deleting all the [ __ ]
tweets
i usually i do usually acknowledge that
i've deleted stuff yeah so i see you
again i really
if i tweet something that like comes
across the wrong way or i think would
hurt someone's feelings that doesn't
need basically if i feel like i'm not it
doesn't need it i want to hear is that
what you're about to say is that what
you can say hurt somebody's feelings who
doesn't need it
correct yeah oh
christmas some of us need it
some people really need to have their
feelings
i like to i like i try to be targeted i
try and i try and make my decisions
about what if i'm not saying the thing
i'm trying to say then i'd rather not
say it because i've certainly tripped up
in the past where i've tried with right
intentions to say something and i've
just framed it when can i raise one more
fact about this article i thought it was
interesting i do need to go to education
on something too
destroyed i need to go
no go ahead i need to go in like two
minutes but i want to know what mike is
going to say no no no no no no no no no
no i made your point i'm not going to
leave on that
so it doesn't change things what's
interesting is these percentages that
are in the article or at least on the gi
doubles are from the 284 people who
previously bought call of duty i was
going to say so these oh yeah so it is
an audience who are into call of duty
who are answering these questions which
is interesting and go some way to
counteracting the kind of pax audience
effect that you talk about not the whole
way for sure but it is interesting that
that i feel like that just that does
equal that out it it literally bought
call of duty
in like 1999.
it says in the last five years
it says in the last five years
so they did do that due diligence with
this part okay okay i don't [ __ ] fall
with the article i think it's an
interesting thing yeah
first of all somebody took the
opportunity to to
stop sticking i'm not arguing with you
troy like for sure i just thought that
was an interesting bit of detail i don't
i know i know i know the point you're
making it's cool
here is to me mike what you've proven is
every time you see an article
don't just stop it i should not just
stop at the headline
i should go deeper unless it's like the
rabbit holes like you have to leave
these 10 celebrity
you know
whatever
but you could leave the problem i think
those pages are so much headline yeah we
do have a headline culture and most
people will see the headline and then
did you see that oh my god that they're
all all of a sudden there's 50 000
people that are dead
it's like
of of what you did you do any further
thing and we've we've kind of uh i feel
that as a society we kind of like
advocated the responsibility of our own
research in lieu of just kind of ad
hocking somebody else's opinion
very passionate about media literacy
that we should be encouraging people to
understand how to read headlines and how
to read articles correctly and get
information correctly it's it's such an
important
south part
i i love that disagree with me that that
is the purpose of discourse that is the
purpose of all of this i don't always
want us four of us to agree on
everything i like it when we disagree
because i get smarter i learned
something that i didn't every time
somebody disagrees with me it challenges
my opinion or reaffirms something within
me no it doesn't no it doesn't try
well that was some audio i'm very sorry
everybody the audio is what it was there
i found myself trying to figure out if i
needed to recreate that
uh effect on a voice i don't even know
how it would do it i don't even know how
he did that it didn't sound like bad
signal it sounded like he was gonna
drink almost
yeah it was interesting yeah um but it's
fine the the intention there was he came
in hot and i appreciate it it was about
video games that's a huge win for us
that was good content and apparently
we're a popular video games i didn't i
genuinely didn't know the podcast was
popular that's good
yeah we have about 80 000 listeners per
episode no
what i especially i know
absolutely
i mean thank you audio thank you thanks
for being here
but at the same time like yeah that's
amazing
feels unfair all right what i especially
enjoy
amongst our
dear listeners
is when we actually talk
about one thing or we talk broadly about
games the whole time and we get these
like
this isn't the [ __ ] i am here for kind
of kind of comments how dare you stay on
top i feel like we have some good memes
that uh i nobody's noticed this so i'm
just gonna call out my own joke i'm
following
everyone on the podcast and also greg
miller from the official twitter account
i've never noticed that that's totally
great oh it's very i can picture you at
like midnight
like giggling to yourself as you follow
him i am one of those yes but aren't we
literally like on the top ten aren't we
like only one or two below kind of funny
isn't that the ultimate level of this
joke is to overtake kind of funny and i
was listening about like if we did it
that's how troy wins i suspect
i think that we have very different
sources of listeners i will do whatever
it takes to win
was going to bring that up i was really
curious uh
your thoughts on the the like weird sort
of mini internet scandal around this
idea of content creators and the [ __ ]
storm of of like
this took
only seven weeks to make and has a
bigger audience just as fast and like it
was like a hilariously sort of dismissal
of the idea of you know piggybacking on
a thing doesn't let you eliminate the
time it took that original thing as part
of your calculation of your of your it
reminds me of the threes thing was it
was the game that ripped off threes was
it 1024 i don't remember the name but i
know what you talked about right you
know i don't know about that i know that
or ridiculous
yeah i remember i remember rami has had
lots of fun with like clones and and and
uh yeah yeah i think i think they're
they're luftwaff
what's the game called the frozen
luffros yeah remember that one had the
same it was like the app store and had
like just clearly it's that game well i
think games do it regularly tencent does
it to its own games
tencent on the app store will take games
made by another studio but that they
have funded or published and copy them
uh routinely in a way that i find very
strange they
will i don't really i think it's maybe
so that it's like well if you leave 10
cent we have your [ __ ] game anyway
because we remade it as well
it's also interesting from a copyright
like copyright when it comes to game
design is fascinating in the in the
sense that it doesn't really work like
you can copyright
uh if someone were to you know i mean
squid game for example the the guy doing
the youtube version of squid game is
legally an interesting ground because
he's taking a lot of elements that are
protected from a copyright and legal
perspective with games core mechanics
it's very hard very expensive and almost
impossible to enforce to copy that's why
they do patents instead right
yeah because you can basically get
around it that way but then a patent is
a very is a very involved process so
like it's outside of the possibilities
of nindy but like there's not it's it's
kind of it's
one of the kind of the biggest risks for
a game developer is like if you come up
with something innovative there's not
really a lot protecting you from another
company coming along and duplicating the
game bit and the thing is with games the
game bit is often the important bit when
um you know uh when fortnite was
inspired
uh by uh pub g
they didn't use any assets from pubg
they didn't use any artwork they didn't
copy anything that was uh copy written
but they did
definitely have some inspiration in
their mechanics
from things in that game and there's no
legal recourse there and neither should
there be i'm not that's what i'm saying
it's like
i'm not attacking epic or no i wouldn't
want there to be but it's like it's
different
you'd be limiting game development if
people were
taking those ideas and copyrighting them
as well exactly yeah we all benefit from
that yeah all benefits we've talked
about that on the show as well that kind
of the gdc thing that kind of the game
developers we love showing people how
our magic tricks work and that's why the
industry moves at the base it does it's
interesting with squid games it feels
like that's applying kind of the same
logic because if an indie game came out
tomorrow and actually this happened so a
week ago i think i retweeted it like an
indie game that is very obviously
referencing metal gear solid strongly
like their sound design their art they
are going to make a metal gear solid
game and everything but all the
copyrighted bits of metal gear right
and we kind of as a games industry we
kind of celebrate that because that's
fun to get back and it's fun to do that
stuff we i think with tv and film that's
a bit more of a that's not quite as
explored an area the kind of the clone
movie is something that's not
respected in the same way as it would be
in the indie game space or in the game
space in general no one really bats an
eyelid if someone comes out with
something that's like another game right
add something really cool to the mix
because they're all like i think we do
really like all games have something in
common um to give context to this
assuming that we've moved on from call
of duty it seems like we have we feel
like we covered that and so have 60
percent of the 40 of the audience
apparently the audience um so what we're
talking about now sorry it was too
easier joe costed i know you were
offended advice i like it
not not at all
cheeky just being cheeky it worked
it's it's advanced
um it's bands it's yeah it's
british that people we're we're good at
two things
colonization that had cheeky jokes
pretty good tea though um which is also
technically stolen that's part of
colonization disregard so if you go
there's a brilliant eddie is odd thing
there is literally nothing anything that
is considered british is definitely not
british we stole everything we're
horrible people trumpets i need to not
do that again on this episode so [ __ ]
woke mike jesus i know i do like
so um what we've jumped into here if
anyone's missed the context is
mr beast is a youtuber um who
does a lot of stuff for charity i think
he generally mostly does makes a lot of
pretty wild crazy content
and he made a video that is squid game
in real life
where he
spent several months recreating all of
the sets of the original uh brought in
456 people to compete to win four
hundred and fifty six thousand dollars
um all of which was donated to charity
and
it's virtually just like an exact copy
of the actual squid game and his quid
game in real life um is what he has made
and it blew up on youtube just enormous
views
uh and so i don't think mr beast himself
did anything wrong all he said is 42
million views in a day i remember when
i'd be excited if a video broke 10 views
i'm literally living the life 13 year
old me would dream of every night and
i'm super grateful nice tweet that's
cool and he did something that i think
is kind of cool the video is someone
else right who held it up the person
we're mad at is some it's this is the
[ __ ] problem with twitter and i did
it too is some random [ __ ] dude with
like it's no followers you you don't
have to retweet it you do why do we care
no i i didn't at least i didn't quote
you i just replied
their tweet is gone the tweet is going
on hunting yeah they clearly
dog never would have expected that they
maybe don't even have the like the
literacy to know how people would take
that when they don't have a following
what are we [ __ ] doing but anyway it
was a really [ __ ] dumb tweet it was
dumb but i will also
um
uh say
in this in the sense of they they didn't
deserve a dog piling that
that that they un that if they deleted
the tweet they un invariably got a dog
piling and they didn't deserve it from
the standpoint that
their tweet was stupid but it actually
wasn't malicious it was celebrating the
idea of a creator economy that you can
its crime was ignorance which is why i
didn't dunk on it because i was like
this guy's just he's not seeing the
whole picture be this doesn't seem like
a bad person who's like no he's not
being mean at all um so
a lot of people felt like it was an
attack on artists no no that was [ __ ]
dumb shut up like i i mean okay so the
tweet is it's from john joshua everybody
please don't go get mad at him uh it
says mr b squid games video 103 million
views in four days it took seven weeks
to make netflix's squid game series 111
million views in 30 days it took 10
years to make more views less time fewer
gatekeepers that's the promise of the
creator economy so the part that i was
like okay i don't know about that is uh
the suggestion that
mr beast's squid game video
only took seven weeks to make when in
reality because he literally copied sets
and games one for one yeah he didn't
have to do the creation part which takes
forever so no you have to add the ten
years on to that seven weeks his took
ten years and seven weeks
the squid game took ten years so
technically this good game took less but
i mean the stats are wild like to see
that that video did did get more views
uh way faster than the original uh seems
seems worse i mean netflix is a
subscriber service yeah so you know
there's a big op there's a big factor
operating there yeah it's also about
cumulative versus okay like so squid
game the reason it was slower was it had
to accumulate an audience whereas the
point when that youtube video came out
there was an audience who already knew
it's also one of them's 25 minutes and
one of them is a whole series there's a
but i mean
i don't even feel like it's worth
getting into like it definitely
is a consistent trend at least from the
patterns that i've noticed i'm sure
smarter people have better studies that
uh if you piggyback off of a popular
property and make youtube content around
it it will do well
um people like seeing what's the thing
we have to reference in this episode
last week was ghostbusters what's the
thing oh uh daredevil i've seen all the
youtubers talking about daredevil really
this week apparently i think daredevil's
the thing that you have to you reference
but the thumbnail for this episode is
this in this episode we talk about
daredevil we'll do that and then just
let people get to this point at the
podcast
every time um that's it just a picture a
picture of ben affleck
as daredevil is that a thing why are
people talking about daredevil like the
20 year old
i guess because it's he's rumored to be
in spider-man isn't he oh i didn't know
that's true
interesting
so i think there was a trailer so
usually wouldn't they use the pop
culture youtube wouldn't they use the uh
the the daredevil tv show
daredevil oh they would i'm saying we
should use both like just for fun why
not
that'll be great for the uh for the
algorithms
to be the guy who optimistically finds
the
interesting nugget of truth in every bad
take and to be that guy
i do think the thing that's interesting
in that the tweet is highlighting that
is correct and interesting
is that once you've gone past the idea
bit which of course we all know is 95 of
it
there is the actual execution of an idea
has fundamentally changed if you have an
idea for a netflix show versus if you
have the exact same idea for a youtube
video one of those is a lot easier to
get executed on absolutely than the
other thing
that's the interesting gatekeepers is
100 correct you can just make something
now you don't have to have somebody else
you know you can make a film with a with
an iphone
um perfectly fine and i think that
that's awesome that rules and again i
actually like what mr beast did i think
that this is a cool thing um that you
know potentially also benefits
goodgame's creator in any case because
it'll bring more of his audience to that
show like it's it it repeatedly brings
it into
the news cycle i think it's cool um i
don't have any problem with even
replicating it uh
it especially when you're donating all
the money to charity as well is
obviously helpful um i will say this
this [ __ ] on twitter is driving me nuts
that anytime anyone does anything
related to squid game which a lot of
people are doing right now
uh people keep going oh you're really
missing the point of classism in korea
i keep being like
you can have fun and play games throwing
a rich guy party come on trying a rich
guy party is a little bit missing the
point that's going to go back they know
that it was a bit like obvious oh i
didn't see would someone have a party
was it was it um chrissy teigen was
chrissy teigen wasn't it
oh that's actually the celebrity party
well but that's bad that's right that's
the only one that i'm like well she also
like probably has like a mansion and
[ __ ] but like i'm talking about people
oh
amazing if that was like performance art
if there was like a meta there was a
knowing meta layer to the so generous
like you're
i'm saying wouldn't it be amazing if
that was like the chess move they were
playing with society yeah
but that's you're right alana because if
your argument is making money from squid
game is missing the point of squad game
then netflix missed the the director
writer
missed the point of sweet game no and i
think you can still make the point of
something and have fun with it that's
that's the point it's like i keep seeing
it for everything where someone talks
about squid games you missed the point
of classes in korea like no they know we
know what the [ __ ] show is about
people are just having fun okay shut up
like it's driving me nuts because it
happens for every like youtube person
who's like just doing a fun thing in
minecraft at this point people like
classes
you don't know [ __ ] anything about
classism in korea shut up
god
come on but i feel like this one uh i i
do think that yeah the video that he
made is really fun i think this dude who
tweeted this like i think my reply was
something like i think what mr beast did
is really fun and cool but i think it
it's absurd to say that
it only took seven weeks to make when it
took even more and that ties directly
into everything that we were just
talking about in reference to game
development which is that literally
every game that comes out is a product
of every game that came before it and i
often think about how interesting it's
going to be
when we don't have
most game developers growing up on the
same games oh sorry
directors because most of our directors
are like
i would i don't know probably
35 to
50
in that range that's how i feel today
yeah you're about 25 to 50. um i play
five to fifty everyone's played ocarina
of time and the amount of interviews
that i've done where people have
explicitly referenced ocarina of time
goes from
uh
like people at double fine to people at
platinum games
ocarina of time it's it's going to be
really interesting when when we don't
have the same foundations of games in
our directors and and to see what
like references or inspirations are
pulled in and how much games might
change or like lose certain shackles
because we didn't all have the same
history of these words i'm super hyped
yeah i'm super hyped for when game
directors haven't all just had a kid and
they're processing that
there are a lot of children have there's
a lot of video yeah children like being
a dad that's kind of a thing right yeah
i love that i don't know if i'd say what
he's doing yeah you just you directly
attack five if troy was here he would be
pretty annoyed at me right now i
apologize um but yeah i think yeah i
think a diversity of experience and life
is gonna lead to cool more varied games
it's interesting when you go back to
like early early film
so because so many of the early pioneers
of film were like magicians
so much of the very early filmmaking was
basically like traditional magic tricks
you made citizens interpreted on film
you guys should know that citizen kane
the director of me or smells yeah so i
know that uh that's pretty much the last
of us of movies
so he i remember reading
he said
the reason that citizen kane did things
differently was just because he was
ignorant and didn't know any better he
was like i just didn't know the rules so
i just did whatever i wanted and then he
just changed a bunch of [ __ ] because he
didn't have the people who do exist
who'll be in europe and be like you
can't do that you're not allowed to
that's not the way that you do it so he
just [ __ ] made something and i think
that that is definitely a cool part of
the creator landscape and it goes in
waves
it goes in waves right like it's there's
a really i've been reading um some by
some biography some biography stuff of
spielberg and like spielberg and lucas
are from that first generation
of film directors who were taught in
school how to be film directors and
that's where a lot of their stuff kind
of changed the game
and then but then they become the
establishment and there's new punks and
there's kind of and there's this
cyclical thing that gaming you're
absolutely right games haven't really
they've built and built and built but
they've not really had the punk moment
yet where and there also crucially there
isn't
well and this this is something that i
think does need to shift in the next 20
years there's not the same degree of
mobility within games as there are in
movies you're your interesting indie
film director is not going to get put in
charge of the marvel movie in the game
space right now that's not
your if you're
not going to get to the direct
the next last of us doesn't happen yeah
no one's calling phil fish to direct the
next call of duty
that would be an interesting game um but
like there's there's no one that's not a
path that exists and that means the
people people who become directors in
aaa space off you know obviously usually
very very talented awesome people but
they are people who've grown in the same
system and the same kind of career path
as their bosses you kind of you don't
have that broad range you can't
necessarily direct a game
i couldn't do it i'm a super experienced
director of indie games i don't think i
could go in and lead a triple a team
also in the game that wouldn't work the
business structure
the business structure of the two
industries is so wildly different from
each other because you know like you
look at someone like
neil druckmann at naughty dog you know
he was there
as a sort of more normal employee before
he was the director of the last of us
our co-director i suppose more
accurately
for years like you know kind of making
his way up
working on the prior naughty dog games
that kind of thing film
is far more kind of like cobbling
together this you know mission
impossible style like you need your
demolitions expert and you need your
this i knew that and with the exception
of like so many movies are about putting
a team together like that's pixar being
one of the very few exceptions of like
they've kind of got this little brain
trust of like andrew stanton and pete
doctor and and uh
and uh brad bird where they would like
work on scripts and be hatching several
films over a long period of time and it
was a lot closer to a video game studio
type like we all are sort of we work for
pixar we are essentially employees
uh you know that most film studios you
know marvel obviously
um has some you know like
the kevin feige and the sort of there's
there is a degree of
staff uh but they they they they go
looking for interesting people they
bring the new blood in each time don't
yeah that's how they reinvigorate them
and you see the same thing happening
with star wars now as well it's a real
bummer that the games industry is like
one of the industries that
you
you see so many job listings that are
like must have five years and ship two
games you know
it's because it's a software industry
that started making creative content
true it's fundamentally rooted forever
that i think that so much of the
draconian ip language that at least i
face in my contracts
it's not necessary they don't realize
they don't they don't realize that it
will pose zero problems for their game
if they don't own every thought i've
ever had about music and and and and and
utterance i've made about it but they
are
and but you know i'm on both sides of
that conversation so many times yeah and
i don't care
it's a real problem i don't begrudge
them saying we need to own this outright
you know it's part of it because their
legal team is saying we need to and
there was you know there's probably like
one random case
that's a precedent you know here or
there like everyone always talks about
alan wake having having bad uh music
licensing and getting pulled off of
steam because of it uh like you know
there's but that's the one in a billion
um and the reality is you know the the
the contracts um
we're here to help you you know like i
as a composer i'm here to to help you
achieve your vision and there are
ideally
multiple variables that we can play with
in forming a contract to make it as
mutually beneficial as possible but
because there's this inherited software
industry like
you i mean the most extreme versions you
know spent i don't know how true this
still is but i would think it's still
true i remember uh
from software engineer friends of mine
saying that you know at least in the old
days i if not still you go get a job
like as an engineer on the windows team
at microsoft it's like even [ __ ] you
make on your weekends
they automatically oh i had to legally
get the rights to thomas was alone yeah
i think i can say that publicly i could
probably say that publicly i had to
literally like walk into the
cfo of the company i was working at the
time and just like basically ask him to
give me the rights because they owned
everything i come up with in my own time
fortunately for me they they literally
said to me like this isn't going to be a
game that does very well so don't worry
about it you can have the rights to it
and i will forever be grateful to that
guy it's basically the action figures uh
george lucas moment no i had that at
both i mean yes but to a slightly lesser
extent it also ties in alana the thing
you're saying about the experience thing
also definitely ties into
was it last episode or a couple of
episodes about we were talking about
like the lack of a middle class in the
games industry that essentially you're
either very small and have no money or
you're very big and have all the money
and those are the two kinds of game
developer who don't want to bring in a
junior because if you're very if you
have no money you want to just get like
the experienced person who's going to be
able to do the thing and get it done and
out the door and if you're um you know
mega studio you don't want to hire
people who are just starting out you
want to get good people and you can
because you're you're having a mistake i
mean it used to be that we had this
middle class that would kind of train
people up and build up people but that's
kind of
there's less of that now there's still
obviously some of it but there's less of
it
i technically was hired as a junior
and if you thought about that in any
other industry i feel like it would be
wild because my resume
is
studied writing at university for four
years professional writer for a
decade and
paid a decade that's been my job um i
have worked on
six games
uh and i'm a junior where in any other
industry
and i like fully i'm happy to be that
that's all fine with me but in any other
industry junior is like out of college
there's no way yeah
and like i also had to be very
established in the industry and have a
reputation and like have people have
written the things i published on
websites that get millions of readers
it's just that's so wild and that's not
how it used to be like to be clear like
there was like when i came into the
industry i did walk straight out of
college into a junior role but that was
a point in time where it got more
competitive
is it because it got more competitive
it's what i said that there's not enough
studios with that on-ramp
that the real the true junior the kind
of the junior you're talking about
doesn't there's no real place for them
because what so there's company like my
first job was a company called blitz in
the uk which you've definitely never
heard of but everyone worked there right
didn't like everyone work at every it's
a it's a joke in the industry that if
you ever run into someone with an
english accent
they definitely got their first job at
blitz but that's what i'm talking about
they got their first job of blitz
because blitz made
kind of what would be ungenerously
called kind of shovelware like the games
that your mum got you for christmas that
you really didn't want but it was an
amazing training ground and because the
budgets were small but there had to be
10 projects so they had to keep bringing
in talent and then they didn't really
pay as much as other companies so people
moved on very quickly so they had to
keep churning in new people it was kind
of a it was basically like a finishing
school for gamedev that's awesome though
and and it served a real role and yeah
if you run into anyone in the games
industry over 30 who's got a british
accent they had their start there and
that's what and i'm sure there are
similar there were similar studios at
that time in america in canada in every
major games development hub in the world
and those kind of died because they
weren't cool enough to be the indies and
they weren't big enough to be the mega
studios so now getting your start is it
is much more competitive because there's
just less jobs because like i said
people either need someone who can get
it fixed right now and they don't want
to risk getting someone who doesn't know
what they're doing and they don't have
the infrastructure to like train someone
up on the job
or they can their naughty dog and they
can get anyone they want why would they
go to people who are less experienced so
it's it's a kind of unless they decide
to be nice people and bring in people
and that's the it's now an act of almost
charity whereas before it was kind of
supported by the market so it was more
financially viable for companies to do
it which encouraged them obviously to do
it
so it's a weird moment for games there's
a woman on my team who
i won't name because i worry that people
would go get mad at her for this though
what i am saying is extremely positive
um who is not a gamer does not really
play games does not have
a knowledge of a lot of games hit me
not a gamer um and it's actually a
breath of fresh air
like those people are so easy
so good on teams
is wonderful because it's like she
doesn't know
the rules so she breaks them and we're
like oh great uh she doesn't know
what gamers will will like or dislike
she doesn't understand the youtube
culture like she doesn't know about any
of it and thus just like pitches and
it's it's like it's like having someone
who's unbiased yeah it's super valuable
and i feel like you would see people
argue on twitter no no no you can't you
can't have a non-gamer
what is this on my wall is by concept
eyes it's a you won't be able to see it
it's like a sketch of megatron it looks
cool because i'm so cool it's really
cool by one of my favorite kind of
concept artists i've ever worked with
guy called martin johnson who and i
quote hated video games because they're
for [ __ ] losers but he worked as a
concept artist in the games industry and
exactly what you're saying he brought so
many interesting like aesthetics and
ideas in for the dweebs he was making
games for
game developers like massively benefited
from this guy being around and game
players will have had all these fresh
experiences where it's like wow this
doesn't look a thing like alien or star
wars that's interesting totally was
because of artists like this who don't
who are not part of the same nerd
culture that yeah i don't think the
woman i'm referring to is nerdy she's
watched tv shows i've never heard of and
loves them you know um and yeah and to
be honest that goes so far that goes so
far so many so many ideas whenever you
see and it's hilarious to me whenever i
see this like often when you'll see like
some viral tweet about like something
really original in a game you'll look at
it and it'll be like oh they're just
referencing like that movie that no
one's watched who plays video games or
it's just like it's this fashion idea
that's from this or it's a specific kind
of art and that's not to knock those
people it's brilliant that they found
that angle but like games benefit so
much from that fresh blood and it's it
sucks things what you're saying is
exactly true that if you said the name
of that person there would be a kind of
game and none of them listen to this
show because all of you are awesome but
the kind of game
a kind of gamer who would go out and
make you know send nasty stuff because
how dare you that is what i worry about
yeah she sucks because i'd love to give
her credit because she's great but um i
don't want to do that to her but
yeah that's definitely a thing where
it's like
i would argue that if i were in
uh i mean i am in a hiring position but
if i were like a direct position that i
would probably want mostly people who
have worked in the games industry for a
long time or uh gamers on my team but i
think that having different backgrounds
is extremely helpful like like different
backgrounds not even just in terms of
literal diversity
um in terms of like
she comes from tv
that rules it means she doesn't have any
of the like
the the rules that we have set in our
minds or the inspirations like the
ocarina of time like she doesn't have
any of that stuff and yeah i feel like
it's it's just as valuable to the team
as as
a lot of other kinds of diversity can be
too funny i'm always of two minds on
this on this subject because i get asked
this all the time by composers who are
trying to figure out
their place in the world do you think
you could do your job if you weren't a
gamer i feel like yours is very
different that's that's exactly the
question i always get do i need to play
games to pursue music in in games and i
always say look
for me personally
the path i've gone down the way in which
i've interacted with the teams i've
worked with the way in which i my ideas
tend to form
in in on a given project
is deeply interwoven with my experience
as a player and trying to and and even
the fact that as a teenager i flirted
with abandoning music and becoming a
game designer like i took c plus and was
sure that that was going to be my route
for a couple years
and and i uh and i and then i obviously
backed away from it but it always i
always kind of had that seed of
i like to try to look at the music from
a design standpoint in fact a colleague
of mine guy whitmore who now works for
the audio production company formosa but
was the audio director at popcap for a
while doing um peggle and stuff
uh he he i
always refers to like
don't call yourself a video game
composer call yourself a music designer
and i always liked that a lot
it's it's it be it it belies
the difference between scoring a film
and or a tv show or writing an opera or
making a record or any of the other ways
a musician can use their
their skills bizarrely technically two
different jobs in the games industry but
i feel like i could very easily call
myself a narrative designer
yeah and i think that's pretty i think
that
yeah like an experienced designer all
those kinds of things to me are an
interesting
like on one level it's just sort of
semantic but it also does show that
you're not thinking purely in the way
that a script a screenwriter would so
it's like on the one hand
a deep fluency
like you know you when you look at
someone like hans zimmer
and you
watch the way he talks about the films
that he works on he's basically
a co-director of the film he is so wired
for the language of film and tv he is so
to him it is always about storytelling
it is never about the music and there's
just endless countless examples where
you can see that in action and you see
it in his music that's the funny thing
as much as his music has taken on this
life of its own outside of what he does
and there's so many like kind of
zimmer-isms that that get sort of almost
they become their own self-sustaining
cliches they're never born out of this
oh i wanna here's my
like
my hit tune that i'm gonna hide in this
score but like is in reality just to
sell records or whatever because there
are some composers that do have that
kind of secret agenda um
he's it's always in service of
of the film no matter what it is and so
it's like well i always say you know
if i was a director and i was hiring a
composer and i had two candidates in
front of me and one of them spoke my
language with complete clarity and the
other one seemed completely at odds
the odds of me choosing
the
the latter seems very low because this
is someone who i'm there's a certain
amount of trust there tends to be a lot
of anxiety around music because it's
like
it's you know like the joke in the film
world especially this is less true in
the game space i find but
um in the film world you know often
especially if they go to film school
they have experience writing directing
editing
shooting acting the the joke is
typically the reason they're so anxious
about a composer is it's the only job
that they can't do on some level
themselves
that's 100 my issue when it comes to
working composers you've just summed up
my yeah i think i've even i've even said
that to you like that it's
the least comfortable i am as a director
and that's a common can't really
it's exactly what austin's saying is i
can kind of draw and i can kind of model
and i can kind of animate and i can kind
of code but it's like it's the one
discipline i have zero personal skill in
so i'm not that's interesting
not comfortable so it's why it's like
that's why and i and i empathize with it
being like this kind of outlier black
sheep of a of a of a uh of a
contributing
discipline to a to a game which is why
all the more reason i would think if i
was talking to a composer that said
don't even think of me as a composer
think of me as a music designer i want
to talk about your systems i want to
talk about the way that you're tracking
your game states or bla blah if they
suddenly know if they can speak your
language instead of you having to speak
theirs it strikes me as eminently
appealing but there are countless
examples of of really interesting stuff
happening when somebody
says i want somebody that's clueless
about all of this uh uh you know i mean
like an example
um
of uh a couple years ago in the world of
film there was um
this movie under the skin followed and
then this movie um jackie with natalie
portman both scored by this young i
think she's british i can't remember
though um i i should let me look that up
her name is micah
austin do you think do you know her name
is micah
and she composes no sorry i'll let you
finish well just what uh just uh yeah
she is english singer um
she um
she kind of uh made some ripples in the
composer community when she was giving a
q a after
uh her they they screened jackie um
she was i think she ended up getting
nominated for an oscar for that score in
the end um and she's someone who came
from the world of sort of like
quasi-avant-garde pop music
uh and got plucked into film as someone
who doesn't speak the language of cinema
and she overtly said i don't like i like
to write the music and ignore the film
the film is distracting i don't i want
anything to do with the footage it's
kind of up to the director to decide if
they like it or not in the all these
self-identifying film composers in the
los angeles audience were kind of like
who the [ __ ] do you think you are you
know and and then it was like she
laughed her way all the way to the
oscars for that uh and so it's like it's
also kind of how game composition works
in a lot of cases right that you're not
you're not composing the music to like
footage of what the game is because the
game isn't there yet right so often it
is
more hand in hand like that right that's
that is part of what like at one point
in my life i might have been more
sort of puritan in in and would be the
type that folds my arms and feels very
cross
with the young micah levy over over how
dare she be different uh from the tried
and true method of like analyzing every
frame and blah blah now i realize
you know the there's no denying uh that
the art benefits from different way from
people to tackling in different ways and
i always come back to this one moment
like here's why i said i'm kind of of
two minds because i love studying i mean
i got a gazillion books on
the the the art of game design and well
that's no bitter library but don't do my
thing troy's got his poster stuck on the
wall but yeah these are just my upstairs
but that's true that's true that's just
our podcast you're fine
you know the thread that that that
unites most of my books is that they're
about these arts and that's why i love
doing this podcast and it's why i like
listening to other podcasts where they
they i they you know like or or every
frame's a painting youtube channel
things like that or nerd writer and all
these people that are analyzing you know
storytelling and the craft of filmmaking
the craft of the you know game makers
toolkit all these places where you just
there's a constant way to sort of see
what people think about this and how
they and and so i love that but i'll
never forget the thing that always i
always keep in check and on alana i
don't want to forget that you were
bringing something up so i'll just say
that the um
i remember i once went to a screening i
feel like i may have told the story here
before so forgive me but i once went to
a screening of a film that i was getting
ready to score they were they were
showing kind of like their first viable
cut to some people some trusted friends
to just get some feedback on on the edit
and this director friend of mine who was
the guy who had recommended me to the
director of this film so he was sort of
he came along as a friend of the
director and i hadn't written a note of
music yet or anything for this we were
all watching it clean
and it's a good film
but i remember
afterward i was talking to my buddy who
had recommended me for the job in other
words the guy who was not the director
of the film we just watched and he goes
he goes
that guy
uh
you know referring to the director he
goes he's clearly of you know a really
solid he understands the mechanics of
storytelling and everything is kind of
like almost too perfectly in the right
place because he said
every line of dialogue sounds like it
was written by someone whose knowledge
of dialogue has come from a lifetime of
only watching movies
like
it did not feel
like oh it didn't feel authentic it felt
like he grew up watching movies until
one day
he just started making his own and
there's no like intervening life
to diversify the perspective so if your
diet is solely movies you're gonna just
rehash an interesting criticism the ones
that have already been made yeah and
it's the same with music i remember john
powell the very celebrated film composer
um you know what sometimes i've seen him
do events where they say what advice do
you have for young composers and he goes
stop listening to [ __ ] film
soundtracks all the time
because it was like well curated
ignorance my writing definitely doesn't
come from that does it do you write that
way mike i feel like if i write and i'm
trying to pull inspiration for something
it is way easier for me to pull it from
something in the real world something i
care about someone i know something that
happened to me
than from a guy right like a game
designer so i'm very mechanical so this
is actually where i'm at with the with
the next script is like i'll write our
script which is literally characters
saying i am angry at you i have failed
so i do that too i'll do all of that and
then
i do that as well yeah exactly yeah but
i don't pull any inspiration from for
characters from other characters unless
i need to find their voice and then i go
i'm thinking this actor in this thing so
that then you can see how yeah i tend to
do that i'll tend to like dream cast it
and do it that way because i find if i
try and go too natural my stuff is often
very kind of sci-fi or kind of kind of
arch and it wouldn't make sense if a
character sounded like
my mate it kind of does often need but
but all that i'll usually do a dream
casting i'll usually go okay that that
guy is played by this actor that woman's
paper this woman you know it's and i'll
do it that way but where do you pull
your character reference
whether i pull the characters themselves
from
i honestly because my stuff's very
my stuff's kind of more thematic and
story driven i'd say it's weird to
analyze your own work obviously but like
i think i think my characters usually
come about as
needed playing pieces for the story i'm
telling rather than originating with the
character i think my characters tend to
materialize because i need that kind of
character rather than me going i wonder
what would happen to this kind of
character which is more mechanical maybe
but like i don't know it works for the
kind of stories i want to be the sure it
works for the kind of games you know
yeah that makes sense exactly yeah yeah
um austin might be [ __ ] at writing a
soap opera well that's gonna ask have
you ever written a short story or
anything because you couldn't do that
with with that no i'd be terrible at it
yeah i know i'd be terrible at that yeah
i i'd maybe try at some point but i i
would definitely struggle the first time
i tried to write i mean you kind of did
with the um
the uh i'm blanking on the name of it
all of a sudden you're ready
you're you're sort of pandemic uh radio
play yeah
but even that
even that like is very structurally
driven like the first thing i did on
that was i worked out okay it's gonna be
six episodes i wanna hit this beat on
this episode wow you write like a
producer and work backwards that's super
interesting like i would start with the
character buyer it's just how i
i think for me from the game side it's
because so much of making video games is
and you know this both of you it's so
much about writing a list and then doing
all the things on the list and that's
like a lot of a lot of video game
development is like i mean especially
the position that you're in is is as
direct as well means that you are
required to think that way i think which
is yeah so so story becomes similar in
the sense of okay i have a budget to
make seven locations so okay so these
seven locations what do i need to do and
how do i get the most like it's it's
very
it's i guess yeah i write like um i
write like a low budget filmmaker
basically i write like someone who's
actually got like a set of rules because
i'm a low budget game developer right
rules are fun though too
um
do you know of any composers in the
games industry who aren't gamers like
yours is an exception in that i actually
don't know if that would be possible
because what you do is so is so many
pieces it's not just a song
i've worked with one or two oh really
um yeah i guess i'm not i'm not gonna
out anyone for the exact same reason
you're not gonna help anyone but yeah
i've definitely worked with some people
uh well there's some composers
you know there's composer colleagues of
mine that i think wouldn't
uh have any [ __ ] well i mean
here's a really plainly obvious example
but gustavo santellia
who did the music on the last of us one
and two
it's the only two games he's ever worked
on and he made abundantly clear that he
was you know
he was very reliant on the guidance of
both neil and naughty dog and also the
sony creative services group folks
and and and really he was like he said
uh we did a podcast together and he was
saying you know he's kind of he couldn't
even really play the game to just see
how it turned out he literally was like
with his sons
uh and now he's sort of an exception uh
for a handful of reasons um
you know
two-time oscar winning composer
film music and record producer
sort of he's sort of a novelty in in a
way but there are composers who are more
stalwarts who
i think play very little i mean a
composer friend of mine who i don't
think would mind my identifying him this
way is uh gary shimon who did the
bioshock franchise
and um and a handful of other games um
i don't think that he's sort of like
not a gamer in this sense of like oh to
help like like
your concept art like that's for losers
kind of he's not like that i think it's
just you know to him he he
it just was never his thing and it's
also um
um
partly i think that he he he came up as
a composer
uh in tv for years and years he even
worked with mike post uh the composer of
like the a team and all these other
millions of big 80s
and 90s hits you know mike post ran kind
of like a composer collective
uh and and uh gary was i think that was
kind of one of his entry points sort of
kind of to your blitz uh thing that
there are a few sort of composer halfway
houses that exist uh that are a good
training ground and mike post was one of
those the number of people who are kind
of in the
40 to 60 age range who start who there's
like a massive swath of composers of
that age demographic would be like oh
yeah mike post kind of gave me my
my shot uh in the same way that a lot of
the 30 to 50 composers now would say
that to about han zimmer
um and uh
so um
so yeah i don't think gary is
particularly much of a of a gamer uh i
don't think that he you know
plays them with
with much
enthusiasm or like as a as a way like i
would i would work all day on a game and
and then if i feel like okay i gotta go
home and kind of unplug for a bit like
it would i to to then immediately start
playing games is a completely viable use
of my
of my evening but for those who start to
see it as sort of work yeah um
it's not it's not that so yeah there's
also a lot of shared responsibility
right it's like you said like the
composer who's not so into games they
have
you know more like a musical designer or
something that's working with them
technically kind of handling that um i
had it recently yeah absolutely one of
our games i was working with an animator
who's a tv animator like you know for
for uh linear linear fiction linear
television
linear television yeah
basically the only thing i didn't work
on is banner snatch
exactly so
so but she was really interesting to
work with because um
because she didn't know any of the rules
of like how game animation has to work
and you know fortunately i was around
there are others around who kind of
point her to what needed to be done but
she brought so many ideas to the table
it's exactly like you're saying alana
because she didn't know you weren't
meant to do those things in games that's
not how it's done and produced amazing
results as a result so yeah it's it's
it's a weird i think often it's
jobs are so shared and interrelated and
kind of there can be overlaps you can
kind of as a team accommodate someone
who's maybe less technically skilled
in the game some game specific stuff
because they're bringing so much on a
different line it's funny you know a lot
of the an interesting place that a
cousin of this whole discussion
manifests is that especially in the
realm of
the uh
the kind of
massive uh franchise aaa publishers
there is a little bit of a trend that
irks
composers in the game space which is to
go and gustavo is kind of emblematic of
this although to me he's a special case
um
but um just because what he does is
hollywood it's the it's the let's go get
let's go spend a fortune
hiring a highly visible so-called film
composer
um
it's often
it's often
sort of chalked up as well it's often
clayton
it's chopped up as a um
it's chalked up as like a marketing
thing as if as if uh somebody would read
like oh danny elfman did the music on
this game i will now buy it like
like the number of units that that
realistically would move it's like i'm
the only person that would ever buy it
yeah
he's just going to reuse your fable
track well it's so that's that's funny
awesome because i think you have that
effect
yeah you do like it definitely i think
i've even made that argument about you
someone i think you have the effect
where people be like oh it's an austin
victory game i'll play that
yeah and that's useful as well
internally often when you're like trying
to convince people literal literally oh
yeah it's marketing it's marketing
having austin's literal literal
literal units have moved i can't even i
don't even want to say i would but it's
a prestige thing as well it's the um
it's kind of the annapurna effect we
again we talked about opponent i think a
few episodes ago although you have some
interesting articles for me it's awesome
like i feel like games that you work on
have virtually always been games that
i've liked and fit like in
a tone that i like like i feel like if
you have worked on a game i'm usually
going to be like i'm going to like that
game because it's a stephen hawk effect
right it's like there's an actor ethan
hawke i don't necessarily love ethan
hawk as an actor but i love his taste in
scripts because like any movie he's in i
can usually assume would be good it's
the same idea right you're you're
relying on something that's a curation
process yes yeah well
the the the recent uh brush up with this
that i had because here's the thing the
reality of it is that a lot of the
really really big like especially in a
post on zimmer world where
you know
there there's a lot of composers who are
the if you go and you slice the absolute
top of the
the film and tv
uh roster as it were uh
you know there's a lot of folks it's no
secret that these composers are
employing a small army of assistants and
additional composers and engineers and
things so that they can be in like 30
places at once because there are a few
people especially if you look at the
biggest tv shows you'll realize the
composer
is essentially managing a crop of people
writing the music on those and they're
more of the director
than like leonardo da vinci approach
right yeah kind of have a slate of
people and that's not everyone's like
that you know there are there are
noteworthy examples of composers that
have no interest in that model myself
included you know i've i've asked for
help when i found myself against the
wall with a deadline or two projects
slammed into each other in a way i
wasn't able to account for in advance
and i've gotten help and obviously
that's always credited and blah blah
blah but there are also and there are
composers who you know who i resonate
with very much in that same
model uh where you know if if it has
their name on it they pretty much if
they didn't write every last little note
of it they certainly wrote 90 of every
last where then there's others where
you're like they kind of help set the
tone
uh and and sort of get the
thing pointed get the car pointed the
right way i mean bear mccreary is a
friend of mine he once said we did a an
event together once where he got up on
stage and basically said you know when
i'm offered a show i will essentially
score the pilot and then
that becomes the blueprint for my team
uh so that they can kind of understand
what it needs to be and then
increasingly the goal is that kind of
what a pilot is for everybody like
sometimes the director of a pilot
doesn't direct the whole show again if
you if you know this
if you understand that then yes but the
average person
i think watching would see the
composer's name and assume that they did
every last little thing and again i
don't i don't take any umbrage with this
the reason i say all that again i have
no i have nothing but
i i would never tell someone how to run
their business or what to do and you
know a lot of composers bear included
who who you know who who manage a team
are friends of mine and who who i have
nothing but respect for uh and and
genuine admiration of um the thing that
becomes interesting is that there is and
this is i will say i mentioned bear
because i could do so confidently and
this is also what i'm about to say is
not true of him
the the reason why it can annoy people
in the game
the people that are more kind of
specifically in the game space
um
when a big fancy hollywood composer gets
hired to score a film is because often
they
don't understand games they don't care
about games so they don't really end up
doing any of it they just hand it to
their team and go just here's the brief
this is what they wanted because they're
focusing on like that cool movie that
they're actually excited about and so
what happens is the publisher pays a
fortune to get the unnamed assistant
who's do and they're not even getting
what they're paying for so it's like
it's a very frustrating and i i say all
this because i recently did a um
i was asked to moderate a panel with uh
hildegood and a daughter and sam slater
um
hilder is sort of like had the most
unbelievable
run
in the last couple of years where she
worked for you those names are so
specific to their countries of origin
and it sounds like a street fighter
yeah it's very very very british and
very icelandic
um so uh
hilder um
you know was kind of a recording artist
and you know cellist and was working
with um
johann johansson the composer who did
the denivel new first few films before
he died sadly a couple of years ago
but um
but uh because of her collaboration with
him and and contributing on sicario they
they made a sicario sequel that they
offered her and then that put her on the
map
to score uh chernobyl
for which she won an emmy in a grammy
and while she was winning and while she
was in the mid-award season for that
joker comes out which she also scored
and then won another grammy and an oscar
and a bafta and a golden globe and so
she was like everything that can be won
was won in this like 18 month period and
she's one of these rigorously i do one
thing at a time and i don't don't like i
will not
nothing is delegated it's extremely
personal in the way she plays most she
doesn't really write orchestral music so
she's just you know as she she does
there's a bit of orchestra and joker for
example but most of what she does is
like she'll play her cello in a weird
way and then she she and sam you know
who's the producer as well will you know
like they'll manipulate the sound and
create something if you listen to
chernobyl it's highly manipulated sound
and they went to like a decommissioned
nuclear reactor and bang on the walls
and made a bunch of recordings and oh
yeah that's awesome so she's she's very
much the real deal he's phenomenal i've
not seen it i know i should she she's
she's very much the real deal and so it
was noteworthy that with hot like
literally a week into her oscar win and
just seemingly conquering the world
um
she got offered by ea to score the new
battlefield 2042. so for the last 18
months that's all she worked on uh and
and uh and when i and and i listened to
the score and so it's like there's
there's the knee jerk oh here that here
they go again ea hiring some big fancy
like she wins an oscar and they just
they can't they can't uh you know they
can't not to go after her and and so i
opened all i did this panel with her and
i opened it all up by saying i want you
to know what you're stepping into
culturally there's going to be a lot of
composers that are probably looking at
you going who does she think she is and
i said i gotta say
i was blown away by the score to
battlefield 24 too it 2014. it is
typical
[ __ ] it she she really is very good
and also it was clear that she and sam
they spent a year and a half
just extremely dialed in the depth of it
is so it's one of those criticism does
not apply to her
yes and i was saying you represent
you represent the ideal version of this
story where you have found success in
one medium because you are just talented
and another medium said ooh your talent
like
how cool for you to bring your novel
weird outsiderness who doesn't really
speak games i ask them do you play games
sam goes the last game i played was
half-life one uh
like
yeah that's what i said if you're gonna
exactly
one thing yeah that's exactly what i
said i go to you know you picked a you
picked a kind of encyclopedia type good
version you know it's like
book i read was like don quixote so it's
like okay i'm not bad uh so
yeah i uh so it was one of those where i
said you you are a magnificent bucking
of the trend where this obviously wasn't
just some assistant gig because you
wanted a paycheck this is the thing you
poured everything you had into and the
results speak for itself and hopefully
it disarms because i i kind of walk in
both worlds so i i like
i don't like the automatic dismissal of
the hollywood crowd or the film crowd or
the tv crowd because there's a lot of
brilliance but it's not like that is
always unfounded i would agree that if
they're hiring someone and that person
isn't interested and they're like team
that sucks
i feel like you're taking that away from
somebody else at that point
yeah yeah you're just and it's just it's
it's like bad business i feel like
you're spending money on a thing but
isn't that a gamble how do you know if
someone's going to do that or not you
wouldn't right when you're hiring them
there's people where you could probably
yes but uh but uh reputations
yeah
but i don't know if you're not wrong
you're not well at that for that kind of
thing they just make it off but uh
but but uh yeah that it anyway it's one
of those that i don't begrudge
people don't hollywood is an incredibly
difficult place to become successful at
and to become successful at that level
so it's not like these are composers who
are just
you know sort of random nobodies or
something like
it's just an interesting little cultural
thing that i just i you know i back
channel with plenty of friends in the
game space and anytime you see another
one of these announcements of oh xyz
famous film person is scoring a game you
know i just always see the reliable
complaints about that and sometimes i
think yeah i get it and other times i
think you're being unfair
uh and like in the case of battlefield
for example like i would go to the mat
in defense of hilder uh and that score
and ea steve schnur the executive at ea
who does a lot of the he's scared of the
mastermind behind a lot of the composer
hiring decisions across all ea titles
they are consistently very good
he that yeah he's he's some design in
general in ea games is surprisingly good
yeah they don't they they put their
money where their mouth is you know like
steve definitely loves to hire those
kinds of folks you know like he has
regularly hired
you know han zimmer and lauren brauff
and a lot of these people very known for
big uh things but he's but but he has
you know i i would defend him
um in his in his uh
in his choices and and especially on
battlefield where i was just so blown
away so anyway it's a
it's interesting it's a thing that like
culturally that i would never know about
if we didn't have this conversation i
would never have it it's all just
it's all just a tangent off of uh my
sort of thesis statement that probably
got lost in there was that i don't think
that that score suffered for the fact
that she's not a gamer uh yes i think
that it actually may be benefited
but if nothing else it was
non-contributing and it's just her
talent is what made it her and sam's
talent the answer to the question is yes
you can make a video game score if you
don't play video games but
there is a chance that
people won't do it right or want it
maybe an unnecessary filter right like
you're basically you're turning people
away if you make that a
criteria by which you're hiring i'm
fundamentally opposed to gatekeeping
yeah so like i don't i would never tell
someone no you can't you shouldn't but i
just also can't imagine how i would if i
weren't a gamer i just so to me it's
like
it's sort of like this
weird cognitive dissonance of you know
kind of like do as i say not as i do
kind of i feel like i'm much better at
my job because of how many video games
that i've played and that was told to me
in the hiring process that they
considered it to be an asset i'm so
plugged in with video games feels to me
like a benefit but that means that i
have weaknesses that other people on the
team have to fill which my co-workers do
by not having the exact same background
as me but then you're returning that
favor by filling those gaps in their
experience i think for a director
there's an argument that you do need to
play video games to be a director oh for
sure you do yeah yeah
i think that i'd be hard-pressed to i
definitely know game directors who have
a girlfriend who's a programmer who
doesn't play games she's a [ __ ]
programmer she doesn't play games
it's well she's not she's making them
interacting with a game she's writing
it's true
yeah
designers working with her who are
worried about like how the system she's
coding work then it works and it kind of
been doing it for a long time never been
a problem yeah i i
it's yeah it's so it is so funny because
to me the the inspiring
people
are like one of like i love penn
jillette for example like if you ever
watch his uh foolish show where people
it's it's like a american idol of
magicians where the whole point is can
you sit in front of pen and teller and
pull a trick and they don't know how you
did it and if so you win the prize and
it's like the most amazing variation on
the tv contest formula and the thing
that i love about it so there's a lot to
love it's just such a it's just such a
wonderful show but the thing that i love
especially
is that um
uh first off i love that they love when
the the contestants actually do fool
them they delight in it they're like
they're just they're so they're so
excited that they got bested but what's
so cool
is
they
i mean obviously penn being the only one
of the two of them that actually speaks
um
uh
he is a walking encyclopedia of the
whole history and medium of magic and i
just he'll like make a sentence right
he'll go like so that trick am i writing
he'll say just like just does the name
inspired by a rocket ship and they'll be
like you got it yeah because and he'll
be referring to some magician from like
sri lanka from 1921 like it's just one
of those where he he knows everything
about it and to me i get i get a contact
high from being people that are walking
totally encyclopedia rules so
yeah so it's like you know
is there like is there
a composer that is sort of better for
you know their what they the novelty
they bring to it absolutely you know for
sure there's innumerable examples i mean
especially in film you know trent trent
rezner is is a you know powerful
contributor
to the career he's had in the last 10
years he's great
yeah and he's you know he's not he was
not a film composer by any stretch for
the longest time now he's won two oscars
so like i got my social i managed to
track down a social network lp the other
day and i was very excited yeah so yeah
anyway it's just one of those i i i
aspire to be much more in the pendulum
frame i like people like that i love
like spielberg you know who speaks
movies and down to every you know frame
of his being
about something other than games right
in the game space like you can be
uh you know obsessed with you don't need
to necessarily be that level of
encyclopedic about the specific craft
you're in you can actually bring oh no
sure but that is what i mean though i'm
saying i aspire my goal is to
to
like i love learning uh everything i can
about this art that i do because i just
love i l that's i i don't do this job by
mistake i love this job so i love to
ravenously continue to consume like i
remember the one of the first interviews
i ever did was the some nerdy there's a
website called soundtrack.net uh
that uh it has gone quiet but
i mean it's not as big as it used to be
but it was but
12 years ago it was kind of like the the
site for any of this kind of stuff and
remember they did an interview with me
and and it be and it was so clear
from our interview that i was such a
like
sort of fan and student of the me of the
of the discipline before i got into it
that they wrapped the headline of the
interview which to me is like still one
of my favorite headlines ever that
anyone has ever phrased about me was a
soundtrack nerd website that said
interview with austin wintery he's one
of us
uh
and i just remembered lovingly i was
like i i wasn't some like academic
composer or like cool guy who plays in a
band it was like no i'm like a lover of
this world who just kind of like found a
way to somehow make my own music yeah
that's awesome
anyway
a bit of rambling but
i feel like we should wrap it up
yeah
we uh
i mean who are we even who are we yeah
that's true
we're not interested
we did it just got cut off because the
youtube version sorry about that
everybody the youtube version um or the
video file is corrupted at the end so
the last five minutes of the youtube
version aren't there they are on the
audio version but i couldn't think of a
smart way to like
fix that so it's like i'll just send
people to the audio version because if i
were to just upload five minutes i feel
like it would be really i don't know
whatever you could
download which everyone should watch on
disney plus we don't have time to talk
about it but oh my god that's so good i
also play with this and i will play some
video game right now that's michael's
video game director that's austin
wintery he's a video game composer slash
music designer
yes you did say also i'll give you one
sentence
oh i was gonna say i saw people
commenting to for us to talk about
arcane and i've started watching it and
i also would really like to talk about
let's make that a project for next week
i'll try and watch it this weekend let's
do it yeah i should as well all right
bye
bye